hello hello it's Gary Vaynerchuk so Gary
really quick this is kind of like
destiny coming to fruition because when
I was in Pittsburgh when you had
question originally the first one I sent
up an interview and you called in and I
was sick that day and the board up at
the station called me later as the
danger yes some guy Gary on the hotline
who's Kerry and I missed the interview
and I was so embarrassed I didn't even
try to reschedule with you I love the
man don't worry at all this is this
makes me super happy let's rock and roll
all right so here's my deal we know
about the book
p-pardon listen this podcast know about
the book because we're fans right so I
just want to go straight for Q&A love it
give me questions for you and let this
roll okay love it thank you
all right so you are so in tap right now
with music right like you've got a ton
of artists that come in for a scare Evie
come in for daily D all the time
what are you can stop like being an
artist man management probably never I
you know obviously I'm paying close
attention more than ever it was
something that I was kind of subtly into
through the last twenty five years then
a little bit more into that and and but
it's always been a part of my life but
not one that I would talk about because
I didn't know it as well as business and
sports but it was always there over the
last couple years you know especially
the last 18 months a two-year point I'm
getting real real real deep I think I'm
bringing a lot of value I I would be
lying if I didn't say that management or
creating a label has run through my mind
I'm an entrepreneur everything runs
through my mind my intuition is I won't
do either but I also would be shocked if
I'm not doing something in the music
industry over the next three to five
years my intuition is it's going to be
different right like I got into the
liquor store business but I didn't by
doing a ecommerce site when everybody
thought the internet was crazy I got
into the Madison Avenue advertising
world but I did it by only selling
social media which was unsellable at the
time so I think if I was to do something
actually official other than trying to
bring value to people that I like who I
think are gonna be big stars I think
it's gonna come in a form that people
aren't expecting okay you mentioned a
lot especially in your keynote and in
your daily B's that basically like radio
is now where TD was like twenty or
thirty years ago right so with that it's
me as a radio personality because a lot
I watch all of your stuff like
religiously okay and I haven't noticed a
lot of guys have seen you on The
Breakfast Club you know with char I've
seen you with Elvis Duran
but like those guys were interviewing
you rather than like asking you
questions specifically about my the
industry that were in yes so given the
fact that we have to reinvent ourselves
what would someone like me do to stay
relevant in an era where voice is going
to become cake it's actually very easy
as long as you film yourself or Ken or
control it or not control it but to me
if if I'm a radio personality and I have
full control not the station or I'm
aligned with the station to me it's just
having a podcast and just filming the
the content and putting it on YouTube
and Facebook and literally you're as
relevant as anybody else it's like I
don't see radio as this major negative
as long as you also vlog and have a
podcast and make social media content
period that's it right so I would
actually argue being in radio is a huge
advantage right now if you have the
ability to film and also create a
podcast out of it well that's that's
funny because I have a podcast right
it's like oh man this podcast is fire
it's gonna get a lot of listings right
because I do have an advantage over you
know yep
Joe Schmoe yep I've taught it for my
whole career but it's tough because like
I'll even play a clip of a pocket on
you know you have to tear up the rest of
the conversation and that there is like
you're the hoop I'm making tea which I'm
through right so that's the hard thing
it's like people yeah well I mean I
think I think look as a radio
personality I think everybody loves to
talk [ __ ] about the station or the
distribution or things of that nature
but what creatives forget is that
distribution is a part of it right and
being on you know on Westwood one back
in the day or you know on I harder this
you know distribution is part of it but
but to me you know you still have an
advantage of being able to no matter how
much friction you're creating for
somebody who's listening on the radio
it's still more built in audience than
somebody who starts tomorrow and is only
at the mercy of winning in a digital
landscape so you have an advantage it's
just that it's not enough an advantage
for you not to be great at Facebook ads
at doing collaborations at showing up on
other people's podcasts like in today's
world where everybody can win that means
that everybody can win which means you
have to [ __ ] be better than ever
before to break through everybody's got
a hot take on the Drake Pusha debate
everybody's got a hot take on the Golden
State Warriors and LeBron everybody's
got a hot take on Ben Simmons and
Kendall dating everybody's got a hot
take on Roseanne Barr in that world
where you're gonna have to [ __ ] be
better at content and distribution and
so yes it is hard and I always tell
people that like manage so hard I'm like
at least you have a chance in 1982 if
you weren't picked by somebody and one
of the seventeen people that got to have
an opinion you weren't hurt exactly and
I think you know it's funny because I
know it's switching gears but underdogs
gotta grow a lot I think it's kind of
all falls into the same place you talk
about a tea brand coming back right and
yeah it's happening with Kay Swift in
your shoes thank you by the way because
that Clips repair and may like three
more dollars
love it
but it hasn't case with is happening
with champion but like I was in the
shower today and I wanted to take a
bigger step back like [ __ ] it's
happening with there's a new Atari
they just got released there's a new and
television coming out Cobra Kai is like
the hottest show right now streaming so
you nailed you hit the nail on the head
but what I was wondering is is the thing
that's making all this happen is this
direct-to-consumer so you've got for
instance the Atari 2600 which is coming
back that's like I'm indeed go-go's do
you buy that directly right do you have
artists who like then you have a lot on
your show a lot they may not have the
radio play but they don't give a [ __ ]
because they're still making millions
because they're still big because of
Spotify that's right if you look at all
these things that they have in common
with Netflix don't need to worry about
getting a network to sign off on it it's
on Netflix or YouTube breath it's the
director consumer model the key
ingredient and all of these things
coming back and having that audience
that they didn't need to get approval or
a green light from a bigger corporation
yes ish but the bigger thing for them so
there's two different things here Atari
2600 is different than tear a whack or
gonna right so Tara Wacken gonna and
everybody else that's emerging in
hip-hop lil the whole the whole you know
punk rap movement little pump all this
stuff they all built their brands on
SoundCloud Spotify Instagram and so they
didn't need radio play what Atari and
Nickelodeon and Pokemon go are playing
on is brand once something's in your
heart it's in your heart
it's you know plays I also deejay in the
clubs and one of my biggest goals are
the rules is people don't know what they
like but they like what they know
correct and so and so the best DJ to me
is the one that's gonna throw three
songs in the beginning and that are fire
that I haven't heard of and he's and he
or she is putting me on and then out of
nowhere journey comes on and the whole
place you know breaks down to for that
and there are two very opposite reasons
it's like don't play in the [ __ ]
middle either put me on to some new [ __ ]
that's [ __ ]
fire or I better hear that first [ __ ]
sound from hypnotize from biggie or I'm
out right so if I make it fight you as I
had this idea but I haven't done it yet
but I want to bring it up to you because
if I make you to have this idea if I
make a mix of your Monday to Monday
playlist and I mix all the songs there a
lot of songs around the playlist but it
also takes some of your player clips
from keynotes and edit it into the mix
will you live can I email that to you if
I do that yeah and I'll give you some
love for it absolutely okay so if so if
I send email you know he's in the
subject yes Kobe yeah yeah all right
questions from from listeners and from
people that submitted to me room who is
he runs the print shops he said how to
create and put a price tag on their time
you just keep asking for more money
until everyone says no exactly concil is
in the health and wellness space he's
observed trends and products across the
country that aren't available in his
margin yet when it comes to introducing
new products in his market it is better
to be first even though the product is
improving or better to wait for someone
else to take the risk of introducing the
product both okay I mean the answer to
that question is both like every there's
there's a lot you know ones I'll give
you a baseball analogy he's saying is it
better to go 1 for 5 with a homerun
but I might also go over 5 with no home
runs or is it better to go 2 for 5 with
2 singles no that's the question and so
we both understand that was okay we're
here we go a lot of your advice is
geared to like college grads yep what
I'm old I'm 40 what would you be like
what was your voice advice be for
someone who's 40 but starting out where
most of your audience is very high when
they're 20 or 30 what's interesting no
joke I don't know if you saw that I
literally posted a video today to 47
year olds so to me everybody's going
through different things you know I
to your point last 8 12 to 18 months I
found myself producing a lot more
content to youth the
I have in the past which was usually two
more 40 year old businesspeople look I
think the biggest thing with 40 to 50 is
that it's now you've lived life and
you're still young as [ __ ] and you're
like now what right you have like an
entire second life to live and it's a
very interesting time in people's lives
where they have to be really
retrospective of like how self-aware are
they but honestly I think forties young
man I really really do and so I would
say a lot of the advice I give to 20
year olds Maps pretty well to 40 year
olds which is you know take some risks
you've tasted some stuff you know
happiness is the ROI and so you know
figure out what makes you happy is it
the pursuit of money or is it actual
money do materials make you happy if
materials make you happy is that really
just insecurity and you need to have you
know a BMW to make yourself feel good
like what's making you tick but I would
say the biggest thing that I would tell
any 40 year old is you've got 50 years
to live please get the finished or I
[ __ ] up like eliminate dwelling
because you're just starting I really
believe that by the way this is not some
motivational rah-rah [ __ ] I just think
it's true I just think you've got 40
[ __ ] adult years to live that's 20
more than you've lived there's just so
much opportunity one of your best pieces
of advice that really hit home with me
was when you said the enemy of yes if
you did it three weeks ago and it might
not be perfect if but you had the
product outright
um things I really took away what this
is for my wife what did that bottle of
red for under 15 bar I'm a huge fan of
Dolcetto DOL EC tto don't jet d'eau is
uh is a medium bodied red under 15 bucks
that massively over delivers on the wine
that it delivers I'll tell her that do
you see a possible area to flip with all
of the Cleveland Indians virgin
that has a logo of our happy bird up in
the air are they oh wow you know what
I'm not usually I'm good on culture are
the Indians changing their logo or
changing their name no I'm still able
they have to get rid of the chief wahoo
so the Hat they have now my my intuition
on it is the answer is gonna end up
being no because there's just it's all
supply and demand this is why everybody
got [ __ ] with 1987 to 1994 baseball
cards and we were all told they were
gonna be worth money
thus we all saved them but there was a
million of them there's so many [ __ ]
pieces of content out there with chief
well if you look at the things that are
collectible I'll give you one of the
great inside tips on how to make money
on collectibles all right bye [ __ ] that
is towards the end of a franchise being
cool for example right now I would buy
an enormous amount of 2018 original
produced Harry Potter [ __ ] because it's
towards the tail end of its era which
means they're producing these Harry
Potter things in much lower quantity for
example the first Star Wars toys the
most valuable Star Wars toys were the
power of the force figures that were
made in 85-86
because nobody gave a [ __ ] anymore and
they didn't make a bunch and they got
destroyed and they got like thrown out
the most expensive you know the rubber
wrestlers from the 80s that I'm obsessed
with one big bowl yes yeah they're
called ljn's
the most valuable ljn's are not the
first ones they're the last ones they're
called the black card series they were
towards the end of wrestling so people
you need to buy things that are made in
limited supply but the equity of the
franchise is very great so like whatever
is made towards the tail end of
something being cool and culture is what
you want to buy and then recall it on
the flip 20 years later when it's back
genius
I was gonna ask what would be a very
practical tip for flipping and money
that's it right there
that was super practical and I gave you
even a more example like a hardcore one
Harry Potter merch that is made in 2018
Gold
this pops up I like the Gary B audio
experience you're gonna make my freakin
year it's probably probably is I mean
there's two to three very good pieces of
content here babban shaking his head
wildly so I think you can get some love
well you know we do have one of our guys
that works for you DeeDee Kirk we had
him on a podcast right literally a week
before he went to move to work for you
based on the rented virality yeah
amazing where we go I love that man it's
and you know I love what you're doing
with twitch we just started we started a
Twitter station we started twitch
channel here for radio station my boss
is looking at me like I have a dildo on
my head but why does the radio station
gonna have a video game channel last
thing that's worth mention is why our
sweet o there of course isn't worth
comes off did you happen to catch the
fact that I played Tyler in Nintendo
hockey last night and beat him 22:7 in
Game one then he told me I'd never beat
him again and the next game it was 12 to
1 when he had a mercy rule out dude I'm
just waiting free to create your own
track the vaynermedia track and
Excitebike I by the way excite bug is so
[ __ ] gangster it's the best it's like
the best bad game ever you can't land
that jump your guy always humbled down
the ill nest man dude so much great
content I appreciate you making the time
for us I appreciate you taking the time
you know you're super busy
the funny part is I went to New York in
4a see 100 Jingle Ball I tried like
literally every attempt to find a record
rep who knows you none of my records up
contacts know you hey oh my god you're
in the same [ __ ] city and then the
funny part was the hotel that I stayed
at one of your videos I forgot which one
it was this is dailyvee but there was a
snowflake
light on the light pole okay
no mic care beads on your doubler I love
that Thank You Man this was super
enjoyable guys I appreciate it
[Music]